everybody welcome back to LED live we're
gonna talk about love today
what are 10 principles the Bible has to
say about dating find out on this
episode of LED live alright guys today's
show we're gonna talk about love since
it's coming up to Valentine's Day and
everybody's got little hearts on their
minds maybe everybody everybody I don't
know why would keep looking at candy I
think this show is gonna be like
directed towards you a little bit
obviously we are three married adults
but you know what we we need this advice
just as much as I think anybody that's
in the dating field dating pool because
we all three have daughters we do yes
and even though my daughter will not be
dating it's all right yeah she's
actually going to right that's right I I
told my daughter you know I will be
choosing for her she said okay dad
that's fine but this is good information
I think just for people you know parents
young parents coming up to you know
their kids when is appropriate to date
all of those questions I think you need
to make those decisions and just like
Daniel purposed in his heart and I think
we need to make these decisions before
we cross that bridge because a lot of
emotions are brought to the table in
that this being a week before
Valentine's they I want to share with
you guys a couple of little statistics
about Valentine's Day they say about 54%
of Americans will be celebrating
Valentine's Day you guys celebrate it to
find celebrate yeah it's over do you get
chocolate candy roses
do you give anyone a card it depends I
guess it depends on if you have half
somebody because my wife was always told
me it's also a single Awareness Day
little cool yes fast a little candy and
stuff we be my Valentine I remember that
if you always feel left out or like if
some kid didn't get enough or whatever
like that yeah a lot of guys you know
they buy like a dozen roses or whatever
I have a tradition of buying my wife the
whole bush nice and you plan it yeah
cool how many roses you have out in
front of your house then oh I got some
by the by the house some in the yard
some out by the street my keys my keys
just overtaken my road all right so then
with that how much money do you think
people spend on average in the u.s.
versus Halloween you know I actually
think it's quite a high number because a
lot of people tend to forget and then
they buy it last minute and it's
probably the double the price yeah
so what do you think all I can do in
this country yeah in this country 80
bucks 80 bucks yeah that's really the
price is right
that's a reasonable number here we go
the average person will spend 136 57 I
think my wife would shoot me money to
spend on an experience I think it's
worth it but it was just like flowers
chocolates and stuff yeah think about
dinner that's 40 bucks yeah I like the
element of surprise like you know
similar send a massive bouquet of
flowers to your wife at work or
something and be super obnoxious so
everybody has to like you know be like
oh wow you got the greatest husband yeah
one day all right here's another
statistic right here the total spending
on Valentine's Day is expected in our
country to be 18 billion dollars be
you're on strike chocolate that is a lot
of chocolate listen to this one jewelry
is the most popular gift with one in
five consumers purchasing it for the
holidays and they will spend an average
of four point three billion dollars or
not necessarily an average but
accumulated spending on that that's a
lot of money it is okay the two billion
on flowers are you guys kind of adding
these numbers up in your head these are
kind of a
money right the most popular is
obviously roses roses I like roses I
think they're one of the most beautiful
flowers out there as well how much money
you think we spend on chocolate you mean
nationwide yes seventy seventy percent
of people will give that almost 1.7
billion dollars that's a lot that's a
lot so if you add all these numbers up
there is an incredible amount of money
being spent on this particular holiday
greeting cards cost a ton of money I
personally like the ones that the kids
make you know my kids are always crafty
and knock out those things and you know
it cost construction paper and it's a
lot more sentimental I mean than saying
oh wow you found one that was
pre-printed right somebody wrote this
for you yeah you know the e cards are
kind of cool sometimes too you know they
pop out and somebody does something
really funny or you can like put
someone's face on it and they can dance
around it's kind of funny but that's
that's literally how much money people
will are projected to spend on
Valentine's Day does anybody want to
take a guess what it would take to cure
world hunger a lot less than that sure
world hunger world hunger they've done
these things they've done these studies
and obviously this number that I'm about
to share with you is a very wide-ranging
number and the reason why is because
there's a lot of factors that play into
why world hunger there's there's weather
there's you know things that are if
those things change then it changes
obviously how easy it is to to help feed
the world but it's actually 10 to 50
billion just throw out there okay that's
a pretty good number you want to guess I
think it's in the billions for sure okay
so this is from GlobalGiving
I actually looked at a ton of different
websites and this same number popped up
on multiple different websites so here's
the number they asked to me that it
would take a range of 7 to 265 billion
dollars to solve it was in the way on
the lower end yeah yeah but just just
just to give you an idea of that number
we spend so much money in this country
like like you know the rest of the world
is dying and with the amount of money
that we spend on
some of these like holidays we could
solve some of these problems in the
world how about one day of indulging in
something that doesn't even matter
a rose that's gonna die a chocolate
that's gonna put weight on you or
whatever man if we could just really go
on strike for one day and send all that
money that's right man
so here's here's a piece of
encouragement to you guys if you don't
have a Valentine's Day you know what why
not get involved in a ministry and show
some love yeah show some love I mean you
know our ministry operates off of love
as well this is not just a pitch to to
obviously donate to our ministry you can
go to patreon and check out all the
perks and all that but I mean it give to
your local church give to some ministry
that you really a child yeah a child
like share some love with the world I
think that is a very noble and good
thing and you know put that in your mind
when you go to spend money on your
significant other there's a lot of ways
that you can do something very sweet
very nice and it won't cost you a
hundred and thirty-five dollars yeah so
just think about that so let's get into
this guys what does the Bible say about
dating anybody what does the Bible say
mm-hmm you should be equally yoked there
you go okay yeah but death but that's
marriage or dating
well one leads to the other so yes yes
but specifically dating what does the
Bible what's the advice that the Bible
gives to us about dating how about this
it really doesn't say anything mmm it
really doesn't it really doesn't and and
with a question like like marriage and
you know this topic of love it's such an
important question I mean this can make
or break your life literally you choose
the wrong person for life and it can
drastically impact your salvation all
you no desire to even want to be a
Christian or or be saved or whatever I
mean if that person that you will end up
with is like yeah
really want to have anything to do with
God a lot of times will default to that
lowest common denominator so here with a
topic that's so important like that why
do you think the Bible doesn't have
enough just a lot to say about it I will
teach his principles and those
principles apply broadly to a lot of
things so you know and I think the other
thing is a good chunk of the Bible so
two thirds of it is roughly roughly the
Old Testament Scriptures right so these
are written in a Hebrew context and that
culture and probably a lot of the
surrounding cultures they had arranged
marriages you know
this whole dating idea right even yeah
it wasn't even a consideration probably
at the time right that probably came you
know lady later from other cultures you
know influencing ours right you know
right when you were of age in a biblical
context it was pretty much that you were
picking a mate yeah this concept of I'm
gonna just kind of try all these
different things and see if I what I
like and if I don't like yeah right is a
foreign concept and I think you hit the
nail on the head
it is principles that the Bible really
discusses we only have examples and
stories of people in the Bible but there
is no thus say there's no hard line
there's no you have to do this and that
and the other you know so I think we
have to kind of take some of these
things in context look at them and so
that's what we're gonna do we talk about
these ten principles that the Bible
actually gives I want to I want to throw
this out there who and how you date is
in as important as when you date okay so
think about that for a second ponder
this I think there is a lot of young
people like everybody's gonna say okay
you're ready to date at age 18 or
whatever right but there's people who
are thirty years old that are not ready
to date
does that make sense sure so age is not
a barometer fro for exactly when you can
get involved in
in a relationship there is more mature
young people than there are older people
and so you know that's that's yet all
this has to play into that factor but
who and how is very important I would
argue that even probably the more we go
along probably I would say maturity is
dropping off you know even as you're
older but you take people a hundred
years ago I mean you had to be able to
run the farm as a teenager we will be
able to do every task you had to be able
to you know hold the place down if mom
and dad went on a trip that took a
couple of days or a week or whatever so
you had a lot of responsibility
arresting on the young people because it
was the way society was there's a lot of
physical labor and things it's like
we've removed a lot of that
responsibility from young people as
society evolves and we make things
technologically easier and all that and
so they get to the point where they you
know what what does anybody expect of
them you you know except go to school I
mean what do you what else do you have
have to do it's not like you got a you
know go plant stuff out in the field and
write and harvest it and you know learn
how to shoot a gun in case somebody
breaks in all right you know hunt down
an animal or whatever is just it's
different times
maybe that's why when you see pictures
in the in in the olden days and you go
man that person looks old and they're
like you know more responsible than oh
well we have today I don't know too many
kids sitting around playing xbox so are
you ready to date that's that that's the
question that a lot of young people come
up with you know when am i ready when
can I get involved in a relationship and
in a biblical sense
so I'd say principle number one here is
love God first I mean that's the first
if you learn to fall in love with God
first and learn to keep going to him and
asking him you know what is it that you
want for me in my life that should be
the first principle any Christian should
get involved in and that's the first
person
I believe when you order that event
constantly in your life as the first
thing that you do God wants you to be
happy you know I mean he's got that
perfect person in mind for you
that that literally will be the best
person for you and he's not gonna force
that person on to you if we sit back and
we say God you know I'm I'm willing to
todate whoever you think is is you know
there for me and I'm willing to to get
involved in a marriage but I'm gonna let
you pick God won't ignore you he will
help choose you that's a really good
point
what's that Bible text saying that how
could you love others your brothers and
sisters those who you can see if you
cannot love me though someone you cannot
see do you know where that's from mm-hmm
I'd have to look it up and I don't know
if the top of my head yeah listen to
this Bible verse mark 12:30 you shall
love the Lord thy God with all your
heart with all your soul and with all
your mind and with all your strength now
what comes right after this your
neighbor is or so right in that order
I believe that when that question was
asked to Jesus you know which is the
greatest commandment I believe that he
Illustrated this one first that this is
the primary function when you get that
relationship correct God will help
direct your relationships and and you
know you'll be able to see your human
relationships in a different light as
well the tangka mouse to come have a
number one God first yeah and I have I
have a personal experience with this as
well like when I when I lived in Los
Angeles I dated all the wrong girls I
mean literally I did not do it right and
I'll be honest with that like I I
literally could have destroyed my life
in so many different ways and finally I
had enough bad experiences I literally
went to God and I said I want a
relationship with you I fell in love
with Jesus and I literally was just like
I want nothing but I don't want to see
anybody you know don't want to date
anybody and that's exactly what I met my
wife
Wow so I know that it really took God
was waiting for me to just step out in
faith with that relationship with him
and
all of a sudden he moved forward with
okay here's the person that you know I
have designed for you you're really kind
of explained my my situation I never
even thought of it like that yes exactly
I was at a point where I was just like
I'm done I was like I was actually like
heart broke but I was like from another
girl but I was uh yeah getting closer to
God and just trying to move on and and I
wasn't ready for a relationship when I
met my wife yeah I have a similar
experience but with a different twist my
family had just started going back to
church had not gone anywhere for the
past seven years and so when I got into
college I decided you know if I'm gonna
say I'm a Christian I need to know
what's in the Bible for myself and it
wasn't long after that that I met my
wife-to-be but at the time I just gave
it up to God and I said look you know I
know this is a perfect time for a
distraction to bring a relationship in
because I am coming back to you God and
so I say you know you know remove it if
it's if it's not supposed to be and he
didn't he actually spoke very clearly to
me and you know told me that she was all
right that's awesome
you know it's interesting I'm
experiencing just a little bit of
pressure from my older family members
and friends every time we meet first
question you know what's going on in
that area of your life coworkers it
shows for candy well wouldn't it be so
awesome if the older people in the
church would reach out to the young
people and instead of asking that
question ask how's your relationship
with Christ because they would know that
once the person is solid in that area
then everything will just fall into
place
they wouldn't even need to ask the
question because the person that people
will link up to the people that they're
supposed to be with that's right that's
right that would be that would be
beautiful
number two principle I want to hit is a
Christian should start dating when they
are ready to be married yeah how do you
guys feel about that exactly okay
go ahead speak up what you got
I'd like to define what dating is first
you know because the way I was taught
growing up which now I realize it's very
different from how people view it is
dating doesn't necessarily have to be
one-on-one my mom pushed group dating in
my head from since I was in like middle
school just you know she had the same
thing like you're not thinking about
marriage till your you have your PhD and
things like that but she's like you know
I understand that you probably going to
start developing feelings so she was
kind of ahead of the ball and that she's
saying they don't feel so pressured to
say yes to an individual or to go out
just you and someone else actually
that's not really safe it's better to be
in a group setting and go on an outing
where you can observe different people
in different settings their response to
different things and that is a kind of
dating I mean being in middle school
even high school you're not ready for
marriage but you can start to observe
different personality types what you may
be attracted to versus what you're not
attracted to and you don't have to be
linked to one person you could just see
characteristics of your friends which
will prepare you for later on in life
when you are ready and I think the
decision might be easier I think maybe
there's yet there needs to be a little
bit of a distinction of are you hanging
out or in my ideas of what dating is is
it's like where your heart then begins
to be interlinked with somebody else
like you're starting to have stronger
feelings for this individual than just
your friends you know I mean have you
ever been in a debate the difference
between dating and courting yeah but I
think that you know the heart is is one
of those things that sometimes you can't
control you know what I mean and and you
know you find yourself being like like
like a magnet like drawn to this person
and it's like it beats faster and you
just you know you can't
you you can't you know you can't quite
think clearly and especially when you
are in your younger years thank goodness
that your mind kind of slows down
whether it breaks down or gets a little
older when you when you when you get a
little older you get a little wiser but
I remember being in my teenage years and
and having feelings for girls and then
just not even be able to like think
straight
yeah listen to what your friends say -
yeah there's a lot of I mean if you're
in the dating world I don't know if we
should talk about that but no we should
we're gonna get to that okay
yeah I'm just saying like you ever heard
of like love drunk
or love blind or whatever it sometimes
you just think no man she's the one I'm
in love everybody's like yeah yeah well
to answer this question okay should we
date when you're ready to be married yes
for sure because if you're in a
relationship it's you and want this
other person the end of the day if
you're not ready for marriage you're
just playing with that person's heart
and wasting their time that's right it's
very hard to turn you that off so that
would be being sensitive to somebody
else and also being sensitive yourself
you know I mean I definitely fell in
love with with a very toxic relationship
early on in my in my college experience
and it could have been just absolutely
disastrous and I could not turn it off
and I was a Christian I grew up a
Christian so you know III think that it
would have been wise advice if I would
have heeded this one thing here listen
to what the Bible has to say first
Corinthians 7:2 says nevertheless to
avoid fornication let every man have his
own wife and every woman her own husband
hmm
notice how it says 1 yeah do you notice
that that's drawn out of the text here I
believe that this is this is a good
verse that really illustrates the power
of love our our desires will overtake us
and so in order to avoid that you know
the Bible suggests for us to get married
and that's where I think this fits into
you know date when you're ready to do
this because that's this is human nature
it's going to lead to that ultimate
is fornication only physical I think he
can be mental as well you know proverbs
18:22 whoever findeth a wife findeth a
good thing and obtained the favor of the
Lord so the Bible describes it wants us
to be married right this is a good thing
it wants us to do not just date around
and have fun there's an end goal to this
that the Bible speaks about so you're
talking about intent when you go to date
right are you dating for the purpose of
finding a life partner or are you dating
just because you want to have a fun time
with somebody with some extracurricular
activities involved or something yeah
that's right so here we go Mikey listen
to the voices of those who love you the
most
yeah I mean that's wise advice why would
you want to heat this other people see
things about yourself that you don't
yeah and even more so like like we
talked about earlier the heart is is is
you know when it starts flooding your
mind with all of these endorphins and
all of these feel-good chemicals and
stuff I mean you really do see with
rose-colored glasses you don't always
see clearly and you know stuff just
seems like like on a different level and
sometimes people that are removed from
that situation can look into that
situation saying I don't know I'm
noticing some red flags whereas maybe
you wouldn't have noticed those red
flags advice you know they've probably
done it before and just give you a
clearer word that's right here's what
the Bible says any in proverbs 18:24 a
man of many companions may come to ruin
but there is a friend who sticks closer
than a brother laughter that the Bible
also says there's wisdom and a multitude
of counselors that's right mm-hmm that's
right that's right I put this slide in
there joyful courageous accountability I
think that we as well can be friends to
those around us and and be courageous
enough to to hold those people to
accountability and be joyful about it
you know this is not just something
where you're beating somebody up but you
know you're there to encourage them help
them along and be a friend
to somebody you know I don't really hang
out with a lot of people now in the
dating world
I must have kids yes but for you candy I
mean you're of the age now you start to
see some of your friends really kind of
dropping off like flies you know getting
married and it's happening yeah and
getting engaged and all of those things
so to be a friend to those people and
especially if it happens to someone
that's really close to you and offer
that accountability be courageous about
how you approach those people I think
that's that's that's wise advice
Galatians 6:2 says bear one another's
burdens as so to fulfill the law of
Christ I think that we are to help each
other out I mean that's what the church
body is there for and you know hopefully
you belong to a church that you know you
have some church members or friends that
you know would feel comfortable coming
up to you and asking you details about
your life and and wanting to know you
know hey I saw you with so-and-so or
whatever how's that going and you know
open up some of those conversations
hopefully sometimes especially if
they're older that would be that would
be good to have that kind of a
relationship
mm-hmm do you have like a like a
barometer because I've heard both I've
heard that you know you should open up
but at the same time you shouldn't you
should keep certain things private for
the sake of you know the Union and Trust
and also some people like me dwell on
the bad things you told them even though
it's been resolved in your relationship
and that kind of creates a wedge and
it's this whole big thing that I I'm
wondering if maybe we shouldn't be a
little more well defined here you're
you're talking about accountability
soin countability in what way are you
talking about sexual activity um
intimate activity you know I got
somebody in check like hey you know
don't go too far yeah exactly
I think as a Christian if we knew these
kind of principles and you know to to
let people know you know hey be cautious
you know you know if you seem to be
spending a lot of like alone time with
this person and you know things can lead
to another or something like that
I think that's very appropriate for a
friend to come and open up their mouth
and say something about that I can
remember when I was in college and I was
dating this one particular girl I mean I
spend a lot of time with her she didn't
live on campus and you know I was
immediately just not around my friends
remember any of my friends coming to me
and being like yo dude where you at like
what do you do it like really nobody
even said anything and so there was
really no accountability there for me I
could have been you know doing whatever
and nobody said anything so that's what
I mean yeah so I guess to answer your
question it's not necessarily to share
those intimate details but it's it's to
be honest with somebody and say yeah the
struggle is real and you're right I need
to spend more time in a group setting or
whatnot you notice to to make sure
you're not making a mistake okay I think
it goes both ways if you find yourself
leaning more towards okay I know I'm
gonna get into situations that I
shouldn't be in it's okay for you to go
to one of your friends and be like hey
you know I just want to share this with
you you know pray for me help me out
check in with me make sure I'm like
doing okay I mean that that would be
good advice and by telling somebody that
that kind of holds an amount of
accountability for you you know that's
interesting okay if you yourself realize
that something is up you're feeling
inside of whether you want to reach out
or maybe you want to keep it to yourself
that's also a good indicator whether
you're in a healthy relationship or not
that's good yeah you know I think sin is
able to thrive in darkness and so you
know if you lay it out on the table and
you say hey I really like this person I
really want to date them correctly and
really attracted to them and I'm having
some issues here help me out give me
some advice or whatever like yeah you
can you can oh you can seek that Hebrews
10 24 and 25 says and let us consider
one another to provoke unto love and to
good works not forsaking the Assembly of
ourselves together as the manner of some
but exhorting one another
and so much more as the day approaching
we should be working together I mean you
know it's interesting I put this Bible
verse over a runner running here and I
recently went to a marathon and just
cheer somebody on I mean we set up the
chairs and we were all there and I was
surprised about how many other people
were sitting there like clapping these
people on I mean you look down the line
there's a lot of people that were like
yeah yeah it was like the whole time and
it's like okay these people don't know
everybody that's running by here but
they're just cheering them on and you
see somebody running right I think a
relationship is the same like that too
we need to be like cheering each other
on and working with each other and you
know inspiring each other for good and
you know the finish line obviously being
marriage you know we should be helping
each other out and cheering on like that
so even if you're not necessarily the
runner
maybe you're the cheer squad we should
still be working together for that first
Thessalonians 5:14 says now we exhort
you brethren warn them that are unruly
comfort the feeble-minded support the
weak and be patient towards all men yeah
good counsel basically letting people
you know let them let them know when
when they're stepping out but do it in
love and always in love Colossians 3:16
says let the word of Christ dwell in you
richly in all wisdom teaching and
admonishing one another in Psalms and
hymns and spiritual songs and singing
grace in your hearts to the Lord now of
course these people are singing to
someone that is old and elderly but you
know I kind of wanted to think about
this and say how often do we apply this
kind of thing towards the young - you
know and really just admonishing them
spiritually with hymns with praises and
things that really uplift them into
you know a proper context of
relationships first Thessalonians 5:11
says wherefore comfort yourselves
together and edify one another as ye
also do so the Bible has a lot of advice
for us to edify each other and work
together and we should be building each
other up and this is a very important
part of life
dating can literally swing you one way
or the other so I I would love to see
our church take a more stronger stance
with the youth of our church it's not
just the parents you know it's everybody
that interacts with those kids
so if you guys have any interactions
with kids you know I believe it's our
duty to to also uplift them in this area
okay principle number four do everything
to the glory of God that would kind of
put a few things in context now wouldn't
it yeah hmm
first Corinthians 10:31 says whether you
eat whether you drink whether it
whatsoever you do do all to the glory of
God right you know if you kind of keep
these verses in mind when you are dating
I mean it would keep it in mind with
everything but specifically when you
were dating this this will help keep us
from getting in ourselves into a lot of
trouble and constantly thinking about
you know like how does this fit into the
paradigm of my relationship with God how
is this going to give him glory we
talked about inviting you know Jesus
into our relationships obviously
starting our relationship with falling
in love with God but also when you get
into that relationship
adding God as the third leg of that
relationship Ecclesiastes 4:12 says and
if one prevails against him to show us
stand him and the three for cold cord is
not quickly broken mm-hmm so you know
there's a lot of things in the world
that can break our relationships I mean
I don't know if anybody's ever told you
but marriage isn't always 100% bliss
just saying there are really really like
things that you have to overcome and
things that you have to struggle with
together as a group
and yes to can make that happen but I'll
tell you what I believe that you involve
God into that relationship always from
the onset you will have a strong
relationship so yeah go ahead Kimmy
there was a seminar at my church and
they gave the imagery of a triangle a
sturdy triangle look let me make sure I
do that right a triangle with God at the
top and if any link is broken the
triangle just falls apart so you have
got the top and then you have the man
and the woman and that creates a solid
shape yeah I'm just gonna say if we go
back to this idea being equally yoked
it's really important a lot of people
have the idea going into a relationship
and being very serious that you know
there's a lot of things that they like
about the person but they're confident
that they can change this one thing that
they don't like right and if that thing
is they're not a Christian or they're
not or they're not even they might be a
Christian but like say they're just a
nominal Christian yeah they're just kind
of going through the motions it's
they're an addict or something yeah it's
it's much better to work though through
those things and remedy them before the
marriage than it is after otherwise
you're setting yourselves up for future
heartbreak that was really interesting
when someone told me that you could even
be unequally yoked within the church
yeah absolutely well I mean I think that
you're gonna have you're gonna have
problems and issues and you know we're
dealing with humanity you're gonna have
different desires and and and different
tastes but even inside of the church
let's say you know you grew up in a
household that just loves to have the
clean house on Friday really reserved
Revere that the Sabbath hours and you
know and then you have a mate that
didn't grow up in a household like that
and you know Sabbath it really isn't
that big of a deal to them and they're
going to you know treat it totally
different I think that that that that is
a place where you could really rub each
other
you know in a bad way and not be equally
yoked in that way so not to say that on
every single point but you really got to
think like okay what are some major
issues that that you know if if it
wasn't like what I want to do would this
be a major point of contention yeah yeah
we're not talking you know toothpaste
yeah yeah whether you want to squeeze it
all the way top or you just squeeze from
the middle yeah it's not that so
principle number five is date with
prayer now this one seems kind of like a
no-brainer right you're a Christian you
should be doing everything with prayer
but really like you know remember this
one concept like Keith shared his
experience with his wife really sitting
down and going I'm already in this
relationship God if you don't want me to
be in this relationship I'm willing to
walk away from it show me to go right
show me to go left and God directed your
pass he will direct your paths that's
really trusting God with your heart it
really by putting aside feelings
altogether so often we I think we want
to go you know what god I I know how to
handle this baby right I know me better
I got this and I'm gonna do it but but
but really I mean that's the that's
that's what we need to do my brother I
remember he had this exact same
experience he ended up in a relationship
with a Jehovah's Witness and she had a
terrible terrible upbringing in the
Jehovah's Witnesses Church and she
basically was just like look when she
started dating my brother don't talk to
me about religion if you talk about
original religion our relationship is
done and so when my brother came back
into a relationship with God he
literally was like now what I can can't
talk to her about religion but then he
was like God if you don't want me to be
with her then and you know you helped me
to either in the relationship or you
need to convert her and that's what God
did he actually converted her listen to
what the Bible says in Philippians 4:6
be careful for nothing but in everything
by prayer and supplication and
Thanksgiving let your requests be made
known and
Wow so everything we need to be bringing
to him
obviously such an important matter as
this would be great yeah and that's not
just for the two dating I suppose that's
for the entire community when you're
praying for the youth not just for
relationship with God and for protection
from day to day but also with their
relationships as well that's right
that's right
all right principle number six become a
healthy person yeah this is so funny
going on with my my girlfriends and
we're talking about like the perfect guy
in the cemetery we never talk about
ourselves maybe I should do this to
better myself for him yeah that's
interesting we always assume that we're
fine we are it's really the other guy he
needs help you know that's that's
probably what my wife thinks most of the
time but become a healthy person and
notice notice this picture here this
little plate it's not food that's on the
plate right is this healthy person that
you were wanting to be worshipping God
on a regular basis are you serving other
people are you you know being a good
neighbor and and and helping out your
fellow man do you spend time in a home
group I mean all those things are gonna
help you become a healthy spiritual
individual one thing that came to mind
it probably applies more to the previous
tip about praying but when you're dating
someone there they're putting their best
foot forward almost all the time
especially when you're together they can
tell you how their home life is like but
you really don't know it unless you're
actually with them in their home and I
think prayer is such a vital part
because God will reveal to you exactly
who that person is and maybe not reveal
it but if you give your heart to him and
he maybe breaks the relationship you
just knowing and trusting that he has
your best intentions in heart and is
probably protecting you from something
that you may not even have known about
it's very important that aspect of
prayer because you were going through
the list like how do I know their
worship life and I'm how they treat
their neighbor when I'm not with them
when they're with their neighbor God
will bring that okay to light that's
right so focus on your relationship with
God become healthy in that relationship
with God and and your church and your
fellow man and then you know you will
notice a big difference that's not what
Ephesians 4:22 through 24 says that you
put off concerning the former
conversation the old man that is the
that is corrupt according to the
deceitful lusts and be renewed in the
spirit of your mind and that ye put on
the new man which is after God is
created in righteousness and true
holiness so to become healthy I believe
that God is saying you got to put away
the old ways of thinking they with the
the the old man's got to die and and
really once you give God control over
your life he will literally remake you
in righteousness and true holiness
to me that would be a very healthy
individual so that brings us to
principle number seven if you are going
to be a healthy person and you have
established that then it makes sense to
date a healthy person that makes sense
so often like you said we want to fix
the other person we want to go ah you
know what they're not around the right
page yet but what I'm gonna do to them
they're gonna get on the right page and
that's not always the case
human nature tells us time and time
again we default to the lowest common
denominator so if someone really has
issues and you know an ADD version to
that way of life most likely we are
going to lower our standards to to
accommodate that person in most cases
and if you don't and you're toeing the
line and that other person doesn't want
to be there then it's gonna rub you know
differently in a lot of areas I have a
particular family member that dated
outside of the church ended up marrying
a man that had nothing to do with church
and when she first got married she
really didn't like go to church very
often it was kind of you know she was in
her young teenage college age range but
then when she started having kids she
wanted to come back to the church and
she really drastically changed and then
her husband was like wait a minute
that's not what I signed up for mm-hmm
like I didn't want that and you've done
this full circle and came back to that
and now it's like when you expect me to
jump on board and he just never ever
jumped on board so maybe men need to
have kids sometimes yeah you know yeah
what is it about having kids I just
changes people usually for the better
it's interesting I think that when you
when you really look at your own life
where are very selfish beans and at
least when I was in my early 20s you can
wake up when you want you can do what
you want you can go where you want you
can eat what you want you know what I
mean your life really centers around
what you want to do and then all of a
sudden you get in this relationship and
now it's like oh well I don't get to
just think about me it's like I have to
make this decision with this other human
being and so then you kind of learn from
your marriage relationship but then all
the sudden you have a kid that comes
along and that kid is just like I want
my food now if you don't may give it to
me immediately like this I'm gonna
scream and it's like you really realize
real fast that wow we are we are born
into this thing like completely
self-centered and you know and it's like
you have to learn to basically set aside
I mean you lose sleep you lose money you
lose all kinds of things just for this
other little selfish life to leg exist
and and then you have to you know train
and recreate and and yeah I think there
with that comes the dawn of realization
of you are now responsible for a lot of
this individuals choices early on and a
lot of their shaping in their character
and their future and all of a sudden
you're like thinking about what that
means and that you have this great
weight of responsibility that how are
they going to turn out and I have so
much influence over them you know to to
help determine that in other cases where
people
you know parent does everything they can
the kid turns out rotten anyway or you
parents are rot and the kids turns out
great but by and large you have this
weight of responsibility on how that
kids gonna turn out and it's it's
sobering yeah yeah you feel a lot of
responsibility for them listen to what
second Corinthians 6:14 says do not be
unequally yoked with unbelievers for
what fellowship hath righteousness with
unrighteousness and what communion hath
light with darkness so going off of that
and that you know concept of yeah being
unequally yoked the the the Bible
doesn't ever give us advice to just say
you know ya pick somebody that you know
has a lot of differences than you and
you guys will eventually meet the middle
I think that's that's starting off on a
hard block first Corinthians 15:33 says
do not be deceived evil communications
corrupt good manners so be careful with
your words how you talk with each other
when you talk to you when you talk to
each other yes and what you whisper in
each other's ears those things can
really set you off in a bad direction
and corrupt your good good manners
okay principle number eight have defined
boundaries mmm-hmm
I believe that you need to define these
boundaries before you get into the
relationship as is with anything in life
isn't that interesting how you know I
think the example of Daniel and his food
and you know though his eating habits
came up before he was placed into that
situation so that when he was placed in
that situation it was easy for him I've
already I've already made that decision
also Shadrach Meshach and Abednego
they're standing in the plain of Dura
and when they're literally standing
there in this plain of Dura all of a
sudden it's like everybody's bowing down
can you imagine the pressure on that and
all the greatest the kings and everybody
that's up there and they're like listen
we've already made a decision and the
King goes I'm gonna give you a second
chance mmm
sorry King
right so that applies I also believe in
in relationships this that also speaks
on the danger of assumptions just
because we're in a certain context I
shouldn't assume that they're on the
same page as me we could be on we could
have completely different opinions on
the same topic that's right that's right
Hebrews 13:4 marriage is honorable in
all and the bed undefiled but
whoremongers and adulterers got God will
judge so same act Dave act is literally
gonna get you in trouble in one side of
the fence but is also an honorable thing
that God created it
okay principle number nine be patient
okay turtle in the hair who won tortoise
the tortoise why did the tortoise win
why not the hare hare' like kind of like
used up all his resources right away it
was a little shiny object right so what
what you know what I think the lesson
that we can learn there is you know
sometimes we think that just get into
something really quick and you know that
the race to the finish line but that's
not always the case
we want a long lasting joyful
relationship that is satisfying on all
fronts and in order to have that
sometimes it really takes some some
severe patience and you know the more
patient that you can be the more you
wait on God I believe the happier you
will be in the end I have a question I
have a friend a couple who waited two
years to get married then a couple
waited for months to get married both
are happy at the moment
hopefully that lasts both of them but um
yeah how does that apply to be patient
if you're in a committed relationship
with someone does that also apply with
how long you should wait for marriage I
think that being patient is more or less
if you are not currently in a
relationship and you're just like so
desiring to have a relationship you get
to the place where you know he'll do
I would say both yeah how long did you
date I did it for a year and a half
before I got married how about you about
how how far into the relationship did
you know you wanted to marry this person
first day oh that's that's great so in
my in my relationship it was just a
unique situation all the way around I
knew my wife from growing up from a kid
in fact I used to tutor her third grade
class when I was in eighth grade clap
when I went in I was in eighth grade I
was more friends with their older sister
who was closer to my age but our
families were friends I used to go to
her house on the weekends and stuff like
that and hang out and I left the town
when I was 17 years old so she would
have been 12 my wife and I never was
going to return again and then I
randomly ran into her in Los Angeles and
she was in her early 20s 21 22 years old
and so I hadn't seen her since she was
12 years old and then almost said she
was like 22 and hey hey hey hey but it
was such a unique situation her being an
adventist only only you know only
Adventist that I had ever dated that
when we met back up yeah I literally
said okay God is this is this really the
person that you have for me and I took
out a journal and I started writing
about my experience with her and I
wasn't really a journal or ever and I
wrote in that journal every single time
we ever hung out every single time we
kind of like you know first time we fell
in love first time we like and so I have
this kind of account written down of the
entire time but I think it was the very
first or second entry that I wrote into
there I said this is probably the one I
was three and a half years for us from
dating to marriage three and a half
years mmm Wow half years so I was gonna
say it I would say this applies to both
be patient on the front end before you
you know get to that point and then be
patient and during the process you know
you don't know how soon they're ready
different people different like
circumstances we were talking about this
the other day
my wife's grandparents they
marriage that lasted 60 plus years they
met and married in two months but they
met during the time of World War two you
know it's a different time in place and
at that time in place you know people
are going off to war they weren't even
sure if people are gonna come back my
wife's parents met and married in six
months but they both came from marriages
where the other person cheated on them
mm-hmm so they'd been through a marriage
they knew what it took to make a
marriage work so when they met and found
each other it was an easy decision like
okay yeah we're ready for this we we
know what it takes and so it was more of
a compatibility and you know are we on
the same page spiritually in that six
months yeah we took the longer out three
and a half years my first real
relationship lasted six and a half years
and she was always pushing marriage and
stuff and I just knew that I'm not
completely happy I'm not gonna get
married unless I am and I was you know I
stuck with it to see if things would
change because we got together real
early like while we were still in high
school and by the time you get out of
high school a lot in your life changes
what am I gonna do with my life you know
we were on totally separate paths she
was like ready to settle down and have
kids and I was one of me a rock star
basically so I knew I can I know even
now it would have never worked out so I
see how much being patient can apply to
the woman because it's tradition that
the man proposes so the woman could be
ready to go but the guy isn't for
whatever reason so just being patient
and having God directed him to make the
decision to take the next step that's
right that's right so do you think it's
okay for a woman to ask the man mm-hmm I
think it's fine I mean I guess as a
woman but you know I guess I can mess
with the guy's pride and you don't want
to enter into a marriage I would feel
very ugly you know life
I'll tell you in my relationship there
was no proposal like me and my wife we
started we weren't married yet but we
were starting to study the Bible and it
was just like it was like a mutual
decision like we're like we need to get
married and two weeks later we were
getting married
Wow yeah Wow all right here's what the
Bible has to say song of solomon 8:4 oh
i charge you o daughters of jerusalem
that she can stir not up nor awaken my
love until he please read that I charge
you o daughters of Jerusalem that ye
stir not up nor awaken my love until he
pleased what does that mean until he
pleased is he referring to God like know
until the love he's using it just as a
mask on I think tell it
maybe so telling the woman to not wake
up until a man please um stir up you
should clarify what you're getting at
with it and what you're getting out of
this yes basically not stirring up love
until it it stirs itself up you don't I
mean like don't don't don't hurt
especially force yourself yeah to open
up those floodgates until it's ready to
to come about interesting what do you
think that's what I thought you were
gonna say yeah I mean there's there's
definitely situations where like the
guys push and stuff where we've been
together for three months baby yeah and
and the girls they'll feel obligated or
whatever and they do things that they
regret later because of the pressure or
whatever isn't that how a range
marriages work to people who don't know
each other come together they're married
and they kind of have to like learn to
love each other and learn to like you
know you you know you wonder like how
how could it go bad
I suppose you know I mean what if what
if you know Isaac and Rebecca or
something you know Rebecca it turned out
to be like but but on arranged marriages
you have the people that are putting
these together they're looking at Temper
me
and personalities and compatibility and
all this kind of stuff so going into it
a lot of a lot of these things are
probably figured out by wisdom and age
so when the people get together there's
probably a high chance that it is gonna
work out you know they just gotta they
got to do a lot of the same things that
everybody else has to do you get married
to do it you're gonna learn things I'm
just thinking of like the friends that
set people up on dates and stuff oh you
guys are so much alike you gotta go in a
date yeah like they're trying to like
figure it out and like so many times
this is like match.com we hold it yeah
Psalms 2714 says wait for the Lord be
strong and let your heart take courage
wait for the Lord I think that's great
advice you know I like how he says it
even twice wait for the Lord
wait for the Lord he will he will direct
that relationship but if you wait on him
to make that decision the end goal of
that will be you will be much happier
down the road Isaiah 40:31 says but they
who wait for the Lord shall renew their
strength they shall mount up with wings
like eagles and they shall run and not
be weary they shall walk and not be
faint so if you want to go the distance
in the relationship right then you know
the Lord says wait on him and he will
give you that strength so true Psalms 25
4 and 5 says make me know your ways o
Lord teach me your past leave me in your
truth and teach me for you are the God
of my salvation for you I wait all the
day long mm-hmm
I think it's beautiful that you know
David constantly had this concept and
you know he had a he had a good
relationship with God even though he had
many struggles in his life you know he
understood that concept of letting God
direct his life I appreciate how
balanced it is yes the Lord expects us
to wait on him but there's also things
that we need to do to better ourselves
teach me your paths
and someone is teaching that means the
student is understanding and to know
that they have learned there should be a
change in behavior so there should be a
development of character as well as
waiting on the Lord mm-hmm and principle
number 10 I believe is bring it to God
whatever relationship issues that you
have or that you are you know desiring
to get involved in you know constantly
bring those things to God bring it to
God bring it to God always be placing
those things before him day in day out
and I believe that will make a huge
difference
lay it on the altar before you get to
the altar that's right yeah that's right
as a good that's good one to remember
Psalms 34 10 I'll leave you with this
the Young Lions do lack and suffer
hunger but they that seek the Lord shall
not want
any good thing tell you what you know I
consider that the guys some hungry
laughs right but you know like literally
God being the god of the very designer
of love the very designer of pleasure he
knows what it is that we want and you
know when we put our trust in him we're
not gonna lack in that department
I think we're so nearsighted sometimes
when were in at least relationships I'll
fight if I miss out on this particular
relationship I you know I just won't be
happy the rest of my life but the
reality of it is is God can make it work
with with you know many different
situations many different people and you
know he has that that that person in
mind for you but sometimes he has to
work with plan B C D in en F so you know
put that trust in God and we will not
lack in this department all right any
anything else you guys want to throw in
there before we close yeah my wife
started praying for a future you know
husband at a like 13
and she just you know she had a list and
she would pray about all those things
that she was looking for and you know
there were probably other relationships
that she could have pursued but you know
after after we got married and she told
me he's like you know I'm glad I waited
cuz I got I got everything on my list
awesome Keith and that doesn't have
anything to do with me I don't I don't
think it's God you know working things
out knowing what she would what she was
looking for and finding the right person
so goes back to patience it goes back to
prayer you know goes back to you know
running things by other people and so I
I wasn't I wasn't that I didn't have
that foresight like I'm glad God was
watching out for me I don't know what I
was looking for but God knew you know
and he worked it out I'm blessed to have
my wife so you know it's it's an
interesting thought my kids are so young
you know my daughter's almost 10 years
old now but thinking about praying her
future mate is running around out there
somewhere and the choices that he's
about to make especially when he starts
to get in his teenage years and starts
to become a young adult I mean that's
the person that's gonna be with my with
my daughter and my desire for my
daughter to have a healthy loving
relationship I should be praying for
that person now make wise decisions
hopefully he's connecting himself with
God you know and beginning to to make
God first in his life and so like that
and so you know parents parents of young
kids pray for your kids as mates out
there no matter how small they are and
I've met people that have started
praying for those kids since five years
old you know and even though they're not
going to meet that person for probably
for 10 or 15 years
you know just keep praying that those
individuals will make smart choices and
that they will ultimately lead your
children into relationship with God as
well that you know we'll see them all in
heaven together well I hope that you
guys you know learned a little bit of
something today candy I hope that was
profitable to you guys yes we'll keep
you in our prayers candies phone number
is but definitely if you guys have any
questions or comments please we'd love
to hear about them and you know this is
a time of the year that you know we can
share with someone our love you know we
don't have to necessarily engage in the
in the worldly sense of the holiday but
you know we can use it as an occasion to
really let others around us know that
they are loved and appreciated so make
sure guys you better be thinking about
this you're a week away from Valentine's
what are you gonna do for your special
spouse and we hope to see you guys later
thank you for your love and support on
this channel and we hope to see you next
Friday
[Music]